how are you guys doing today
yeah good it's nice to be here is that
it's great such a change to be able to
do something in Liverpool well I I
actually wanted to say that it's an
amazing matte painting we're actually at
the Four Seasons you know but being
serious a big fan of both of you guys
and Congrats on the movie thank you so
much
one of the things that I find
fascinating or really interesting is
that you both had early you had success
in the early 90s in the UK in making
movies and you didn't transition to
Hollywood you stayed in the UK and
continued making movies here can you
sort of talk about you know was there
temptation to go what was the motivation
for staying that's so it's a good
question in my case the motivation came
before so I went to America when I was
about 27 somebody asked me to come out
right film and I really realized that I
didn't know quite what I was doing in
that it was crucial when I was typing to
know if someone in Boston what they
would have for lunch how they would talk
to their friends what music they listen
to so as I flew home having failed to
write the film I said I'm gonna say
every film that I ever write again in
the street in which I live Notting Hill
and this movie is set in Suffolk it's
pretty well in the town in which in
which I live in which ed Sheeran Richard
Sheeran comes from yeah and unlike music
for me was like I I'm a mad as he is
both of us kind of mad music devotees
and I love kind of America lots of
America but the music here you know and
especially the stuff that comes out of
this tone and the tone Manchester which
is about 20 miles over that way it's
just like unbelievable nourishment
really so I've never been inclined to
kind of leave that behind I've always
wanted to be have that the whole time
really so yeah but I love working it
I've made a couple of films in America I
love working there but basically they
but you're correct I mean I think we're
kind of like we are most of our work is
based here one way and we have remained
here in Britain yeah that's what Tim
Bevan who's working title the producer
nuts when he introduces us on stage
before a screening that's what he tends
to say about suss these are the two who
stayed behind I'm very curious this
obviously doesn't work without the
Beatles at what point in the process are
putting this thing together of writing
it are you saying okay well how are we
gonna get the rights
how we gonna you know and you know what
I mean because without I think I was
reassured we could get the rights I mean
I think we checked before I wrote the
full script because in fact you don't
have to it's not as complicated as
getting the masters so you just that and
so they heard who was going to make the
movie and thought it probably not
something we'll say no to the Beatles
don't they'd have to say oh we think
it's a great idea it's anything to do
with us but we were reassured that they
would be able to get access to so I'm
always curious about the editing process
because that's the final rewrite I'm
curious what did you learn in the
editing room maybe that you weren't
expecting I guess I'll start with that
pre lap the songs so pre lab is when you
start the next scene in this scene and
with songs because you need to complete
a certain amount of them to feel like
you've experienced it so you know that's
a time issue and what you do and it's
our editor John Harris introduced this
style where he would pre like the song
like 10 15 seconds before the scene
happened so that you were started to
feel by the time the song is completed
you feel satisfied that you've heard a
verse and a chorus in or at least and
that the feels like you've experienced a
song and yeah
you actually it's not just been stopped
here's a song stop again here's another
song it feels like it flows through the
arteries of the whole experience rather
than just being single scenes like that
and that's important because you are you
haven't got a variety except that the
Beatles were infinitely variable they're
wonderful choice you know their
creativity was incredible variety but
it's all by warm band really and there's
15 of them but you know I don't think I
hope you never feel like oh god is
another song oh my point of view it was
the same thing which I've had to learn
in every movie which is you've got to be
delicate with the emotional story we did
a few changes about you know what what
happened between the characters and
particularly whether or not himesh was
allowed to flirt with someone else yes
and and he wasn't you know it's bad
enough him not being in love with Lily
but the idea that he would ever do
anything wrong so always in movies you
you're absolutely right
it's it's the last reason Leslie writes
isn't it yeah I'm curious how long was
your first cut compared to the finished
film two minutes of DVD extras you know
set extra scenes that we've actually had
material
well another 25 minutes of that and that
was probably it really we I mean it had
a good tempo right through at the
beginning I think it's too long to begin
with they always are cuz you include
everything but then you learn from
including everything what you don't what
you think you don't need and you could
never realize that we were all geniuses
you can realise that ages are going to
save the money of shooting those things
but you need to shoot them experience
them and and see how they all stand up
against each other and always with jokes
you know the movies it's it's aiming to
be funny and the first time you screen
it there a couple of you realize of
stinkers so I've been saying to daddy
for months darling I promise you take my
word for it
that's actually a lot of that's like so
25 minutes of deleted scenes or is it
that's all I was I'm a big fan of the
film and I cannot wait to see what you
guys cut out well that's very sweet of
you I did a movie called pirate radio in
America and the first cut of that was
five and a quarter out I don't know I
think it was the best version it was
like a very very long documentary but
being serious for a second with
something like that and with the advent
of streaming isn't there if you have a
cut of that is there any way of getting
it out there to actually cuz I would
totally watch that well IIIi will try
and access it you know they talk about
the director's cut
I always describe it as the director's
half cut in other words it's when the
directors drunk he says no it was very
good the FASTA masterpiece exactly I
think I think movies are perhaps cut for
a reason but maybe streaming will change
that maybe streaming or let people
access I always thought it would come
about that people would you see it a bit
with trailers that people would cut
their own versions of films you know
they'd want they'd want to the final the
final draft the final final draft will
be the fans say no no when I saw it like
this I'd like you to do it like this and
then they could already pulse their
version those kind of things will happen
I'd yeah I would love to I have to go
but I would love to see here are the alt
burdens and also is just a film person I
want to see the difference and you know
people can learn from it and well no it
is the editing is one of the guitar it's
it's my favorite bit of the process
because the movie keeps getting better
yeah you know because often you will you
will when you're writing I
when I wrote Notting Hill I wrote and
finished it had to write the whole
second half again so but there it tends
to get better yes yeah absolutely it's a
wonderful process it's one of the hidden
jobs that isn't really given the credit
that it deserves
really it tends to be about
cinematographers or designers or writers
or directors but actually editors I do
without an edit